for those of you that have just recently
joined we are now just under two hours
until liftoff of Axiom 2. it will be
heading to the International Space
Station we have a targeted t0 time of 5
37 PM Eastern Time 2 37 p.m Pacific
weather continues to look really really
great
almost picture perfect I would say
over the last 24 hours we did see an
improvement in our weather conditions so
something called the POV or
percentage of violation which is
basically our chances of violating one
of the weather rules that exist and we
have to follow for that liftoff time and
that percentage decrease to only 25
percent so everything's still continuing
to look good on in terms of an on time
that that liftoff targeting 5 37 PM
Eastern
so we are now undergoing the leak check
of the side hatch
this side hatch will remain closed until
the crew splashes down and 10 days from
now
weather dependent
we can see there inside the white room
as the closeout team is performing that
leak check
this is such a great view because I we
saw the astronauts add their signatures
to the wall there earlier as they right
before they got into the crew Dragon
this was a tradition that SpaceX started
with the demo 2 mission NASA astronauts
Bob benkin and Doug Hurley were the
first to add their signatures to the
white white room wall
and of course the Axiom 2 crew got to
add their signatures along with the
axiom1 signatures and inspiration 4.
they're along the the x that we see on
the right hand side
it's great to think about the
representation in all of those
signatures too you have of course all
those NASA astronauts and various
countries that are involved in that
space program and now with that SpaceX
logo and the private astronauts that are
going up and now the Sovereign Nation
companies our Sovereign Nations that
will be joining for private launches
like today with Axiom it's really cool
to see that diversity and that breadth
of representation absolutely
as I mentioned before we are operating
to a a countdown today that countdown
helps ensure that all the teams are are
tracking to the same milestones for that
t0 time we are running with plenty of
margin at this point in time we are now
awaiting the results of the site hack
excuse me the side hatch leak check
of course we build margin into the
timeline to allow us to re-perform steps
that might need to be done so at this
point in time we've just been flying
through all the Milestones so we are
tracking with uh great uh great margin
at this point
okay well while we wait for results on
that we're going to go ahead and look at
the crew a little bit more deeply
all right the ax2 mission Commander is
Axiom space director of human flight
space flight and retired NASA astronaut
Peggy Whitson during the next 10 days
she'll extend her record as the American
with the most amount of time spent in
space here is a closer look at Peggy
[Music]
I saw the first guys walk on the Moon
Neil and Buzz in 1969 I was nine years
old and I thought what a cool job of
course I was Farm kid from Iowa how are
we how was I ever going to do that I
didn't tell anybody from the time I was
nine raising chickens and learning to
fly and all that I wasn't telling people
that I wanted to become an astronaut
because it sounded like an Impossible
Dream and it wasn't until the first
females were selected and I graduated
from high school and that to me was when
I decided hey maybe this is real maybe I
really can be an astronaut and it became
a goal instead of just a dream
Peggy Whitson became the first female
commander of the International Space
Station she also set records in these
categories most days in space for a U.S
astronaut and more hour spacewalk than
any other woman she understands what
humans feels like really means when you
approach it with that awe and respect
and humility it's like you're you're
doing it justice
the experience of just being in space is
incredibly special and unique but to me
the the most important perspective is
perspective you look out the window you
see planet Earth and it gives you this
perspective of how important that we all
want and we're building this place out
in space to replicate the peace parts
that we have on Earth
I'm really excited to take this crew up
to the space station number one because
they're all rookies and this is going to
be fun to just relive those first
moments with them as they get into space
and and get to see their excitement and
their expressions and joy
ax2 means there's a 2.0 to her career
and now she gets to help a wonderful
comforting to take back next step in its
Mission her Congeniality and her manner
extremely comforting and it gave me the
confidence that I could do this he is
inspiring personally I look up to her
and I want to be like her I don't know I
love everything about Peggy she's my
role model
I'm Axiom astronaut Peggy Whitson
the pilot for ax2 is private Astronaut
John schoffner
a steam Advocate business Pioneer and
lifelong space Enthusiast he's been a
pilot since the age of 17 and
participates in extreme sports from hang
gliding to base jumping to High
Performance Racing let's get to know a
little bit more about John
um well they're fun they help you find
your Edge you know I would say limit but
we don't really want to find the limit
you want to find the edge I think John
is a human Dynamo
he is a multifaceted and
you know it's over and above
I was probably the the outlier in the
group I was always striking out and
doing climbing trees and on roofs and
setting things setting things on fire
I grew up near an airport I had access
to airplanes I started flying when I was
15. got my license
shortly when I was eligible it was just
something I did in the early 60s
actually 1963 when Jim and I began
flying it was big news it's easy for an
eight-year-old at that time to fall in
love with space that was our fun
cardboard boxes rolling down Hills
emulating space training Gemini Pilots
so space just became part of the fabric
of me and it never left
that I heard about private astronaut
travel before a little bit of research
pulled up Axiom axial space and their
mission well my wife brought it to my
attention she saw the news article of
Axiom flying and said hey you can
finally go to space and the moment I
heard about this opportunity I knew I
would be on board he's on a mission to
encourage young minds to use their
imagination and from there he says
possibilities are endless
I'm taking a patch for the Middlesboro
independent school systems this is their
middle school who this year last year
actually decided to become a stem
certified school what I want to do is
show teachers and Educators the value of
listening and paying attention to what
is in a student and helping nurture what
they see in them it's hard to go against
your nature
but if you can listen to yourself and
follow that voice then you have an
obligation to nurture that
I'm John schoffner and I'm the pilot of
ax2
[Music]
representing the Saudi space commission
and serving
asserting representing Saudi space
commission and serving as Mission
specialist Ali al-karni is an Air Force
captain in the Royal Saudi Air Force
we'll be commencing health check for
launch Escape system expect a momentary
flight computer State change followed by
a transition back to pad hatch closed
and Dragons
having trained at King Faisal Air
Academy as well as multiple bases in the
U.S Ali has flown as a fighter pilot for
12 years Ali was selected as an
astronaut in 2020. here's more on Ali
I grew up in the southwest region of
Saudi Arabia in a very small town called
subtilalaya
I've always wondered about planes and
how they fly
back then in Saudi Arabia we did not
have a lot of places or a flying
academies you could apply to so I have
to go and find a place that could train
me
that's why I applied for the Air Force
Academy to be a fighter pilot
the best moments
for me is once I hit the throttles in
full a b and the aircraft start rolling
down the runway
as I take off I watch my shadow and see
how fast I'm going
that gave me a joy that I cannot
describe
I am Alia Carney and I am Mission
specialist one on ax2
being selected to be part of this
Mission make me privileged and honored
to represent my country I was really
surprised about the results out of the
announcement people are loving it people
are super supportive of the mission
I consider myself a newly married I've
been married for three years now and
I've had my daughter she's a 12 months
old and I want to share with him how big
it is what I'm about to do
it is an amazing opportunity to be on
top of a rocket filled with with fuel
and gas that are going to boost you to
space
[Music]
the team is amazing we have worked so
much to make sure we have a good crew
coherence and right now I can say that
we do complement each other
every single one of us has been trained
to do everything regarding this Mission
I would like to thank action space for
enabling us to go back to space and
giving us this opportunity
I have an amazing family they are
supportive of me throughout my career
and I want them to know before I step
into the rocket that I love them and I
will always be there whether physically
or mentally with them and I'll do
whatever it takes to make them feel
happy and loved
[Music]
representing the Saudi space commission
and also serving as Mission specialist
Rihanna barnawi has a master's degree in
biomedical Sciences from alphaisal
University in Riyadh Saudi Arabia and a
bachelor's degree in biomedical Sciences
from otago University in Dunedin New
Zealand here's a closer look at Rihanna
[Music]
including its first ever female
astronaut into space
[Music]
I was always into exploring new things
research was one of the things that
fulfilled that feeling for me trying to
experiment finding a piece of the puzzle
that could solve a mystery I never
thought that I will ever be going to
space but at the same time it feels like
a dream come true it's an overwhelming
feeling of course
[Music]
home for me is a small town my dad had a
little farm he taught us how to plant
that was one of the first experiments
that was one of the most fascinating
fields
my grandmother
to me she is my role model I can't say
that my grandma is my biggest fan and
I'm very glad that I have my grandma's
support
Saudi Arabia will be sending its first
woman astronaut to the International
Space Station rayana barnawi a
biomedical researcher is part of a
private Mission operated by Axiom space
Rihanna she is an amazing scientist
she's done stem cell research and breast
cancer research and we are really
excited to have her on board the space
station doing some of the same types of
things in space it honestly feels like I
am representing old Saudis ambition or
female and all researchers as well it's
a big honor to be able to go to space
and at the same time do the things that
you love the most it's not just that you
have a nation that's proud of you but
you are creating the dream and the
opportunity for this next Generation to
become the next space engineers and
creating the idea that the infinite is
possible and that space is a true
opportunity
Rihanna
[Music]
we're now at T minus one hour 42 minutes
and 55 seconds until liftoff of ax2 we
have confirmation that the side hatch
was closed and we got a good leak check
so everything is continuing to progress
on time great and as operations continue
we want to provide an overview of some
of the science and research activities
planned for the ax2 mission to help us
unpack the breadth of Axiom manage
payloads is one who has helped every
principal investigation team prepare for
this Mission our very own Chief
scientist Dr Lucy Lowe she's at Kennedy
Space Center in Florida with Axiom space
director of digital strategy Sonia
gavonkar McKay Sonya great to see you
and we're excited to understand what's
ahead in the next couple of weeks for
our crew
thanks so much Duke it's great to be
here with all of you as the excitement
really builds toward launch we're just a
few miles away in fact you may be able
to see the Falcon 9 rocket with the ax2
crew on board just over my shoulder and
yes I'm joined with Axiom space Chief
scientist for microgravity research Dr
Lucy low Lucy how excited are you for
what's to come hi Sonia I mean it's a
fantastically exciting Mission there is
an absolute massive amount of research
that the crew is going to be doing and I
can't wait to see them get started and
there is a massive amount of research
they have to do and we have just a
little bit of time to cover it so let's
Dive Right In it is packed for it but
what has been the scientific strategy
for this Mission and what do we expect
to see so the scientific strategy is
really continuing what we did on ax1
which is expanding access to
microgravity for a whole new Global
community of researchers so we're really
excited to welcome onboard our Saudi
Arabian partners and see them do the
research they want to do we also have
some opportunities to expand commercial
opportunities by manufacturing products
in space that could be beneficial for
life here on Earth so we have a glut of
projects that are going to be doing all
kinds of stuff about in-space
manufacturing so we're really excited
about those now you've organized the
portfolio into five main categories and
we're going to kind of touch on each one
of them very briefly let's start with
physical sciences I noticed that from
the list there is radiation protection
research as well as some storm related
research that is looking at how weather
and climate and seeding clouds tell me
what this all means exactly so we have a
really fun experiment that's brought
from us from the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
looking at cloud seeding so they're
looking at how silver iodide crystals
can actually form water vapor in a
specially designed chamber so they're
not only understanding how cloud seeding
could be more effective here on Earth
but they're also looking with a vision
to perhaps extraterrestrial agriculture
so maybe growing crops on the moon and
in Mars in future wow we also have
projects looking at radiation shielding
so the sun spits out a bunch of
radiation so looking at how different
kinds of polymers could actually protect
the electronics on the space station
could actually help with future
spacecraft design and then finally you
mentioned storms we have some really fun
projects where the crew are actually
going to be trying to capture images of
what we call transient luminous effects
okay which are events which occur just
above thunderstorms at the same time
that lightning strikes and we can't see
them from the ground because we're
underneath the clouds right so on top of
the clouds we can see these phenomena
and it helps us understand more about
our own weather and climate down here on
Earth excellent so the next portfolio is
life sciences research includes DNA
nanomaterials and reprogramming skin
cells to help create regenerative
medicine there's also research planned
to build on ax1 science modeling tumor
organoids to better predict and treat
cancers can you break down a few of
those for us and tell me again what we
can expect to see what the astronauts
will be doing up in space yeah
absolutely so as I refer to some of
those in-space manufacturing projects so
the DNA inspired nanomaterial that you
refer to could actually be used as a
therapeutic Delivery Agent in future or
as a scaffolding for degenerating joints
we have also projects looking at uh 3D
bioprinted tissues so looking at liver
and kidney and seeing how they respond
in microgravity which could be
potentially very informative for helping
us understand regenerative medicine
efforts and then we have a whole other
project on stem cell manufacturing which
could actually then help with lots of
kind of clinical applications here on
Earth so lots of research on that end
not even to mention all of the human
research that our crew are very willing
participants in where they're doing all
kinds of experiments to see how the
human body responds to space how it
adapts to microgravity and how we can
use that knowledge not only to make
space travel more safe for humans in
future but also help us understand our
own physiology back here on Earth a
little bit better okay on to Tech the
research being conducted here seems to
be how can we automate more to take up
less time doing things like data
transfer we know about that on Earth
what's it like up in space making
Communications with Earth easier and
literally tracking where supplies and
materials are on board I mean they have
a lot of space up there inside the
building right so they have to be able
to track where everything is loose bolts
and and whatnot what stands out to you
in this research so it's interesting you
mentioned how much space there is up
there because there's fairly limited
space so we have some they can't exactly
so we have some Axiom technology
demonstrations where we're demoing some
of our own technologies that we can use
on Axiom station in future but we also
have some really fun technology
demonstrations from our partners that
are sampling the air inside the ISS
they're using special sensors called
quartz crystal micro balances that can
detect tiny molecules in the air and
tell us a bit about the air quality
inside the ISS wow and then we have a
really fun project from the MIT media
lab where they're looking at what they
call a gravity countermeasures loading
suit or a skin suit which actually
models some of the effects of gravity on
our crew and so it helps them prevent
some of the physical deconditioning that
astronauts see when they go into space
really important research absolutely
what do you think the error is like up
there I think it I hear it smells of
electronical equipment oh okay so so
wait for those little cubes to tell us a
little bit more exactly okay
Partnerships also very important with
Axiom space since it started and it's
really great to hear about all of this
research that's really coming from so
many institutions educational
organizations Lucy how are you seeing
the commercial opportunities evolve and
what's the goal for us long term yeah
absolutely great question so we continue
to expand our Partnerships with a number
of Global Research communities which is
really exciting seeing really exciting
research come in from new communities
new organizations new researchers that
have historically not had access to
microgravity and now we can provide that
but as I said we're also very interested
in opening up these new commercial
economic opportunities to do things in
space that can create materials or
biomedical products that can benefit
life here on Earth because that's
ultimately what we want to do at Axiom
is everything we do in space we want to
be benefiting every human everywhere
which includes not just the astronauts
but all of us back down here as well
well thank you so much Lucy for all your
time we're going to be talking to you
during the mission as well to find out a
little bit more about what's been
transpiring up in space what we expect
to see down here and so much more will
come our way thank you so much for your
time thank you Sonya well that is
amazing groundbreaking work that we're
going to be seeing the additional
insights of these studies and so much
you can follow the efforts as they play
out on orbit just visit us at
axiomspace.com ax2 research we're going
to send you back now to Hawthorne to
Duke and Kate thanks so much guys thank
you Sonia thank you Dr Lowe well
Switching gears a bit Axiom space is
also working to create Partnerships with
companies that you wouldn't typically
expect to hear about going to space some
of those companies end up with some
represent representation on board a
mission as well besides the crew the
dragon is also carrying hundreds of
kilograms of supplies and resources for
the mission most of these materials are
essential as supplies but every Mission
has a few fun surprises one of those is
off one of those that's often discussed
is the highly anticipated microgravity
indicator this is actually the only item
inside dragon that isn't secured at
launch once the crew successfully
reached orbit the microgravity indicator
will begin to float allowing all of us
to visually see what we've completed
during the launch phase of the mission
and to reveal the indicator a fifth crew
member named Gigi here is a very special
greeting from Sharon John and a few of
the younger Axiom family members who
helped prepare the indicator for this
flight
hi it's Sharon John Build A Bear CEO and
president we're incredibly thrilled to
be a part of the ax2 mission to space
thank you so much for this incredible
opportunity we also wanted to be sure
and wish good luck to all of the Brave
wonderful crew members that are headed
off to space and hope that an extra
fifth furry crew member brings you luck
with that in mind we wanted to also send
you off with a very special heart
ceremony as some of you may know we have
heart ceremonies at Build-A-Bear
Workshops but we've created a really
special one for today so what we're
going to do guys is we're going to do a
special heart ceremony so what you're
going to do is you guys are going to
warm up your hearts like this or rub
them to get them nice and warm then you
guys are going to Pat those hearts to
get them started pat pat rub it on your
hands so they can steer the spaceship
and stay on course then you guys are
going to rub it on your ear so they can
hear mission control loud and clear and
rub it on your eyes so they have the
best view of Earth so let's have a safe
and successful Mission let's put the
heart in our hands hold it really tight
close your eyes and make a great big
wish for them
then you guys are going to give it a
really big kiss
good job guys
[Music]
let's see it all right thank you so much
we'll be thinking about all these Hearts
when we get to space
and our little Bear is floating okay
[Music]
wow that was unbearably cute if I do say
so myself we actually have a replica of
the microgravity indicator on board with
us here this is a special edition Axiom
space Build-A-Bear just like the one you
saw in the video Gigi is wearing the ax
emu spacesuit that NASA's next
generation of moonwalkers will use
during the Artemis 3 mission which will
land the next humans on the moon in 2025
using Innovative Technologies in a
flexible design these spacesuits will
enable more exploration of the lunar
surface than ever before
speaking of Artemis 3 and these lunar
missions SpaceX is playing a significant
role in that mission as well that's
right we are incredibly honored to be a
part of NASA's Artemis program to
establish a sustainable presence on the
moon to prepare for Missions to Mars
SpaceX will conduct an uncrewed
demonstration mission to the Moon with
our new starship vehicle prior to the
Artemis 3 mission marking Humanity's
first return to the lunar service in
more than 50 years starship's early
flight tests followed by regular
starlink deployment missions and
propellant transfer demonstrations are
also directly advancing NASA's Artemis
program along with spacex's ongoing
mission to make life multi-planetary
a big thanks to Sharon John and
Build-A-Bear for their support in our
mission we're all really excited to see
Gigi floating around inside the dragon
in the next couple hours to learn more
about GG and all the exciting efforts on
this Mission visit axiomspace.com
we're just over 90 minutes away is the
Axiom 2 crew awaits its 5 37 p.m Eastern
Time liftoff from 39a at Kennedy Space
Center right now quick status update the
crews inside the capsule the side hatch
is closed as of about 30 minutes ago
leak checks are complete we've also had
completion of comp checks between both
dragon and Falcon ground teams uh with
the crew looking at weather right now
the weather continues to be good for
launch and any contingencies if needed
local pad weather continues to be that
25 percent probability of violation will
just watch over the last hour and a half
if we get any clouds drifting over from
inland
conditions in the Atlantic are also good
should we need a contingency Landing
somewhere along the Eastern seaboard
Falcon 9 team will begin bleeding at T
minus one hour and 10 minute Mark of the
Merlin engines and the latest update
we've heard from the SpaceX team out at
39a the support crew is leaving the crew
access arm with the hatch closed all
their work is finished so right now
everything is on schedule at T-minus one
hour 30 minutes and 28 seconds
and with our crew safely inside Dragon
freedom and continuing their preparation
for launch let's head back over to Sonia
gavonkar McKay at Kennedy Space Center
for a conversation with a member of the
Saudi space Commission
Sonia this is an exciting moment for
many around the world but what does this
mission mean for the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia
that's a great question Duke our work
with KSA and men and any partner begins
just years before the launch date we
started talking with KSA about four
years ago and like any commercial
partnership there are a lot of details
to work out and that's especially true
with the U.S commercial company signing
with a direct agreement with a foreign
Nation once you get through the
negotiation process you and get to the
actual signing of contracts which took
place in 2022 then you have to get to
work planning preparing training for the
mission not only are these Partnerships
beneficial for Axiom space and our goals
of building history and expanding access
to low earth orbit but for all but we're
enabling Nations like the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia organizations and
individuals to achieve their goals in
space joining me now from the Saudi
commission Saudi space commission to
share how this Mission and our
Partnerships are so critical to their
Ambitions beyond Earth we are joined now
with just the perfect person to talk to
you thanks so much for joining me here
today Ibrahim let's start let's start
with the Ambitions of the Kingdom what
what brought you to this moment of
course like I'd say like you know on the
personal side I'm space Enthusiast and I
know like there are so many space
enthusiasts there that this in Saudi and
we're so excited like to be here and
this is the first uh mission of the
Saudi astronauts Corp and this program
started uh to begin and it will be a
sustainable program right right but why
now why take this big leap right now
well there's always a lifetime for
um for something this is like a huge
thing space is becoming like more
evolved now and this is the right time
for space and we see like so many
nations are joining the space uh of race
and Saudi has been there 38 years ago
actually with the Prince Sultan uh being
the first Arab and first Muslim to go to
space and we're continuing this uh work
in going with the first female
moment it's such it's such a momentous
moment we talked about the first steps
we talked about the evolution long term
what are the goals for SSC so the
National Space strategy so aims to have
the kingdom to be
um a key player in the space sector this
is just the beginning this is just a
first program and this only looks at the
sector of the human space flight and we
see this Mission as a stepping stone a
stepping stone that will continue to
take prisons uh in space and what what
does the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia have
that's unique that you bring to the
table
um I think you could know lacroianas
like for for today she's unique uh
becoming the first uh Muslim and Arab to
go to the ISS and also first
um it's actually going to be the sixth
country to have uh two um from the same
national uh astronauts in the station so
this is like we said the first step it's
an exciting step how do you feel right
now oh my feeling I can't really explain
my feeling I don't think that I have
enough Force to express my feeling
um we're looking at the countdown we're
so excited we've been waited for this
moment for a long time we're so excited
we're so happy uh we're tuning in uh to
watch the launch
um we can't wait to see them in orbit
and you've spent a lot of time in
Houston with us right through all of the
training you've been there you've kind
of been training with these astronauts
in the same way do you feel like you're
part of the crew or do you feel like a
support system you know to be honest I
wanted to be in the cargo actually
yes yeah I really wanted to go with them
I feel like I am with them in the
journey
um um I enjoyed like every moment this
is the most exciting moment of course uh
I can't wait to see them in orbit and I
can't wait to see them back again and
I'm gonna feel uh like I'm in space with
them but without the zero gravity of
course that's right well it's been a
pleasure to work with you and you're an
entire team I I know that you've your
entire Kingdom of Saudi Arabia feels
like you're going along with this
Mission as everybody looks upward to the
skies for this Mission you do feel like
you're part of the crew going along so
thank you for being such a wonderful
partner with us and we we won all
stowaway too so we'll we'll figure out a
way for maybe the next time you we go we
go on another mission together I really
appreciate it thank you I'll be ready
you'll be ready ready you are you are
thank you so much Ibrahim thank you this
is an exciting time for so much of us
here we're so grateful for this
partnership and so many things that
we're going to achieve today together
naturally today we are focused on the
launch of ax2 and the mission
celebrating the beginning of their eight
day Mission but it is interesting on how
much of this Mission serves its own
chapter in the development of expanding
opportunities in low earth orbit This
Crew is benefiting from prior missions
including ax1 as a way of passing the
Baton to This Crew here and marking it
as that special moment here are just a
few words from Michael Lopez Alegria
Larry Connor Mark pathy and Eton stebe
of the crew of ax1 take a look
dear Peggy John Ali and rayana together
with you the whole Ikea team are
counting down the days the hours the
seconds towards your launch the
excitement is building as you are
leading the way for more diverse
explorers in space
may this journey Inspire your families
and people is the focused numberless
Otherworld wonders but none more
wonderful than men
the impact of your mission will cross
borders and contribute to a much better
world because
there is no dream Beyond reach good luck
Godspeed ax2
hi this is Mark pathey admission
specialist from ax1 and I'm sending out
my warmest greetings to the crew of X2
as you count down the final days before
your big launch uh Peggy and John I'm
super excited for both of you I know
you've been waiting a while for this and
maybe a little bit jealous too uh but I
hope you have a great Mission and Ali
and Riana although we haven't met I've
heard of you guys are a great addition
to the team please take good care of my
friends up there and look forward to
seeing all of you on your side godspeed
eggs dude I am honored
to have the opportunity
to speak to all of you
the crew of ax2
you are about to embark
on an extraordinary experience
I wish I could join you
I know it's been
a great deal of work and effort
but you shall be rewarded
good luck and Godspeed John Ali Ray and
of course dear Peg
you guys must be getting very excited
it's getting real
by now you're either already or about to
be strapped in comchecks probably a
little chit chat with each other but
most of all the excitement is building
and I just want to give you a little
preview that
when the number of digits on the clock
goes from four down to three so ten zero
zero to nine fifty nine
starts to get pretty real when it goes
from three down to two one zero zero to
59 seconds
even more so and you can imagine when it
gets below 10 seconds what it's going to
feel like
so enjoy the ride enjoy the sensation of
floating definitely enjoy the view and
from the crew of ax1 we wish the four of
you got speed
it's absolutely incredible to be part of
this rapidly growing effort and Industry
every Mission points to the next and I
hope you feel the energy and
anticipation like we can here on the
Space Coast do Kate this really never
gets old I say that this is my first
time at a launch what's the energy like
out at Mission Control at SpaceX uh it's
absolutely incredible and I think you're
right it will never get old this is just
really a fantastic day for ax2 and how
great to hear that message from ax1 as
words of encouragement
well as we've mentioned this is
privately funded Mission and so what
that means is that the origins and
primary funding for this Mission are
coming from places other than National
Space agencies so it's not a
governmental government-driven effort
which is unique Axiom space is
pioneering Partnerships between us a
commercial entity directly with Nations
other than the United States which may
sound like a simple thing but these
kinds of Partnerships especially for the
purpose of space exploration are really
covering new ground
we are so proud to be partnering with
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia for this
Mission and while we view this
relationship with them as a partnership
they're also our customer NASA is
another customer in this process they'll
actually be paying for some of Commander
Peggy whitson's time while she's on
board station to conduct specific
science that's of importance to them so
we're very proud to help meet the high
demand for space and research science
and research in space while pioneering
the expansion of commercial space flight
in addition to the first of their kind
Partnerships that Duke just mentioned we
also have a strong and growing
partnership SpaceX and Axiom space
in the space flight business a purely
commercial entity paying another purely
commercial entity to fly humans to space
has been mostly unheard of but our hope
is that it will it will become more and
more common SpaceX is proud to continue
growing our Partnerships with Axiom
space NASA and other commercial
companies who can put our services to
good use for the benefit of humanity
for the ax-1 mission we introduced a
series of digital Collectibles and the
response to those were really
outstanding so for this Mission Axiom
space will continue to push the
boundaries of web 3 by partnering with
several well-known digital artists and
Brands to celebrate the continued growth
of the commercial space environment
Axiom Space 3 is our program that
combines the promise of space
exploration with the power of web 3
blockchain technology
this is a token Gated Community Network
which allows members to engage with
astronauts space technology
professionals and web3 entrepreneurs
for this Mission we'll kick things off
by launching a brand new digital art
collection by Art blocks artist Nadia
Bremer an astronomer data visualization
designer and artist
this new art blocks collection will
feature a 448 for 484 piece
algorithmically generated collection
that showcases imaginary maps of the
stars with unique constellations to make
this collection even more unique the
digital art will actually be initiated
from onboard the ISS by ax2 Commander
Peggy Whitson
additionally Additionally the ax2
digital art collection will feature
works by thank you X an American Artist
out of Los Angeles California
thank you X is sending up a piece of his
physical art canvas to space titled urge
for Perfection he will also be releasing
a commemorative nft which will celebrate
this Mission and the canvas going to
space
this nft will be available for purchase
right at launch and the sale will close
by Splashdown
these collaborations with digital
artists and Brands bring a new level of
creativity and inclusivity to commercial
space Industries like ours for more on
this and all of our Digital Collection
collectible activities visit
nft.axiomspace.com
there you can also find more
instructions on how to get involved and
buy your boarding pass to participate in
all of the ax2 activities
well the most visible visible part of
axiom's work today is these missions to
the International Space Station these
are just the Leading Edge of one aspect
to the preparation for our real goal
operating a completely commercial space
station and laboratory in low earth
orbit
these missions serve as an opportunity
to learn and prepare for how to handle
Logistics maintenance schedules routines
crew volume and every other aspect of
space missions
the roadmap that Axiom space has created
points to some major Milestones to
evolve our presence in space they
include
deploying our own habitation modules and
docking them to the front of the
International Space Station
deploying our own solar panel and Earth
Observatory elements overseeing long
duration space flights of six months or
more that lead to a permanent presence
of commercial activities off planet
developing spacesuits and other
Necessary Technology to live and work in
space and eventually breaking away from
the International Space Station to be
100 independent as a commercial space
station
while the launch of the first ever
commercial space station module is still
a couple years from launch the process
of Designing and now manufacturing have
been underway since 2015. here is a bit
more objects for Falcon 9 status update
go for Falcon 9 status
the F9 team is going to take this action
to vent the manifolds for the
pre-breathed Falcon 9 status this will
be a loud venting so we do expect that
you will hear it in the vehicle they'll
be taking that commanding shortly but
just giving you a heads up you will hear
this venting
okay copy venting the manifold and we
expect to hear it thanks
all right so that was SpaceX core Arthur
and that was a SpaceX core Arthur
barriolt just letting the crew know to
expect loud venting noise again that is
the primary voice of communication to
the crew to update them on status as
well as items like this where
uh they are
um they can expect to hear something
good heads up for the crew there
so talking about Axiom space station
here's a bit more on the current status
currently under construction
[Music]
we are building the world's first
commercial space station one element at
a time we think that what we're doing is
for everyone everywhere this is a global
Endeavor our partner in Italy is in the
finishing stages of building the first
module the first pressure vessel we are
here in the integration and
manufacturing area of Italian space yeah
we have the the two cons that will will
be part of the module is also the gate
to the modular to come in and to come
out the very big cylinder that will be
the core of the module just to have an
idea of the dimension of the real module
you can see me compared with the
structure
on this report all the additional
modules will be docked this is the most
complex piece of the entire Axiom module
[Applause]
one place to build a human rated
spaceship faster than anybody's ever
built one when we look at our roadmap we
look to see how we can double its
capability every five years it requires
a lot of different talents and a lot of
different engineering backgrounds so
we've really expanded the team I'm
working on the time sensitive Network
aspect of the space station so that's
the network have all the flight
computers synchronized and actually
Thruster firing at the perfect time
so this is the command trailer we're
able to control our test stand which
enables us to vary our set pressures our
flow rates into the Thruster in order to
collect performance data at various ofs
and chamber pressure conditions it's
always a blast to come out here set
everything up and start lighting rockets
off
behind us we have the carbon dioxide
removal sub-assembly we're going to be
creating the most uh integrated
ecosystem that has ever been put into
space thus far which is a really cool
thing to be able to say
I fabricate PC boards and cables and
harnessing
because this is a life critical job and
you want to make sure you do the best
possible job
thank you
15 to 20 years from now we're going to
be surrounded by objects that we can't
imagine how we live without that we're
manufactured in space I think there's
another promise too and that's why I'm
really excited about the X2 crew
there is this effect that people have
gone to space and had this is called the
overview effect many people have come
back profoundly changed because of their
experience and I think the more people
that we can have that see the world as
the whole world the better off we all
are
[Music]
incredible to see how much these
missions are able to impact the future
of Axiom station and private astronaut
missions there's so much more underway
that we can't show you just yet but
circling back to the here and now it's
missions like today's that pave the way
that's right around the corner well ax2
will spend less than two weeks in Space
the value adds to our Discovery and
planning process feels like it's years
of experience
we're excited for these short duration
missions and even more excited to be
able to get into long duration missions
as we begin to bring Axiom station
online
but before we get there we still have at
least two more flights to go ax3 and ax4
we aren't quite ready yet to talk about
the details of dates and crew members
but in the same way we're launching KSA
astronauts today we have also signed
agreements with the nations of turkey to
fly some of their National astronauts
and other nations
and it will and as it was previously
announced we will be flying a member of
the Italian air force on an upcoming
Mission as well
between these new Sovereign Nations and
the private citizens who now have a way
to partake in the Marvel of living and
working in space we are truly working to
expand access to low earth orbit for all
and that's not even counting the
opportunities to help NASA Issa and jaxa
find ways to expand their efforts in low
earth orbit
it's all super exciting news and
progress for the future of human space
flight we're really looking forward to
successful completion of this Mission as
well as the two that are yet to come now
for right at the moment let's check in
with John I for another status update
just over 70 minutes away as the Axiom 2
crew awaits its 5 37 PM Eastern Time
liftoff from launch pad 39a at Kennedy
Space Center you've got a view right now
with the crew access arm the seals along
dragon have actually been deflated you
can see a little bit of a gap between
the capsule and the arm the SpaceX team
has left the tower they're getting out
of the hazard area
so everything continues to go on time as
we've got the crew in the capsule with
all activities complete to date
currently weather you can see the blue
skies in the area some clouds around
there we haven't had any updates that
indicate things are better or worse than
when we started the webcast we're still
at about a 25 probability of violation
but everything continues to look good we
do watch the upper altitude clouds as we
get later and later into the afternoon
it's at the higher altitudes where the
wind actually could carry some anvil
clouds back over the pad in the essent
corridor in that case we've got to worry
about things like lightning but right
now the flight path downrange continues
to be good for launch but we're going to
have to watch that until we get all the
way down to t0
now as you can see it's still daylight
obviously at Kennedy Space Center folks
in the local area are going to have a
good view but unlike a night launch
where people all up and down the Eastern
Seaboard of the United States can see
the vehicle you're going to have to be
in the local area to watch Falcon 9 with
dragon take off
you you see right now is looking down
from on top of the service structure at
the top of the crew access arm the
Dragon capsule with the solar rays then
below that is the Falcon 9 and you can
see just a little bit of the transporter
erector the arms actually that will open
up around the second stage as we get
down into the last four minutes of the
countdown
another video Falcon 9 with dragon on
pad 39a
we've been listening in the Falcon 9
team the dragon team they are on
schedule
reporting no significant issues
everything continuing to look good
and one update that'll be a little
different on this flight the first stage
will be coming back to what we call a
land Landing or return to launch site
and so we'll continue to cover that is
the second stage with dragon heads into
orbit one difference you're going to see
this time is given the trajectory of
Falcon 9 when we carry astronauts to
space we can come back now to The
Landing site uh just down from Kennedy
Space Center
but what that means is we're going to
have a slightly different sequence of
burns we'll do the Boost back burn with
three engines as is traditional coming
back to land
the entry burn as we get to the
atmosphere Fringe that's a single engine
it's a fairly short burn we don't have
to slow down much but when we land we're
going to light three engines
now right now T minus one hour seven
minutes 25 seconds and counting
everything is go for an on-time launch
a big thanks to all of you tuning in now
as we welcome NASA and their coverage of
the second Axiom Mission ax2 you're
joining us here with live views from
NASA's Kennedy Space Center specifically
this is the iconic launch complex 39a
with a Falcon 9 rocket and dragon
spacecraft that are in the final stages
of preparation leading to launch in just
over an hour from now
as the name suggests this is the second
flight for Axiom space with a handful of
noteworthy firsts
this 10-day Mission will see the first
female commander of a private space
mission Legend and former NASA astronaut
Peggy Whitson
our pilot John shoffner will soon become
the first Alaskan astronaut and two
national astronauts will be the first
from the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia to fly
to the International Space Station Ali
al-karni and Rihanna barnawi
taken together as a crew this is the
first private Mission with private
astronauts and astronauts representing
non-us Nations through Direct commercial
arrangements and that's just to name a
few
my name is my name is Duke Brady and I'm
a multimedia specialist at Axiom space
based out of Houston Texas and I'm Kate
Tice quality systems engineering manager
here at SpaceX headquarters in Hawthorne
California and as duke just mentioned
our coverage has now expanded to NASA
Television and we would like to welcome
NASA's Leah Cheshire from Johnson Space
Center in Houston Texas hey Leah
hey Kate great to see you and Duke and
I'm excited to join as we get closer to
launch so thank you so much for having
me I am here in Mission Control Houston
where the orbit 3 team is coming on and
taking over from the orbit 2 Shift these
teams are monitoring the station and its
crew 24 7. and of course in here today
we'll be watching the launch with the
International Space Station flying 260
miles over the Southwest coast of
Ireland at the time of liftoff but we've
still got some counting down to do
before then so back to you guys at
SpaceX
thanks Leah now liftoff time is still
holding for 5 37 p.m eastern time and
we're tracking no issues with Falcon 9
or Dragon the range is green and the
weather is cooperating as we saw earlier
uh really Picture Perfect views coming
to us from Kennedy Space Center as you
can see there
now over the last three hours Axiom
astronauts Peggy Whitson John schoffner
Ali alcarney and rayana barnawi donned
their SpaceX suits in our suit up room
and were then transported to the pad
where our crew entered the SpaceX Dragon
spacecraft that you see there live on
your screen
and since arriving at that spacecraft
our crew were helped by the closeout
Engineers to get into their seats attach
their suits to special umbilicals that
provide breathing air and communication
links to dragon's systems they conducted
successful leak checks and
Communications checks with the corps
here in Hawthorne which is the person
dedicated to speaking directly to the
crew throughout the mission
the closeout team sealed the hatch which
also got its own leak check and they
have Departed the pad coming up weather
operators kick off their final check on
wind speeds at the pad before the final
go no-go for launch now before we get to
that final go no go the SpaceX team will
do an internal poll making sure
conditions are steady with Falcon 9
Dragon the crew the range and weather
a lot of things needed to line up there
absolutely now as the countdown
continues we are now approaching T minus
one hour three minutes and 15 seconds
let's take a moment to get reacquainted
with our crew today
the ax2 mission Commander is Axiom
space's director of human space flight
and retired NASA astronaut Peggy Whitson
during her career with NASA Peggy flew
three long-duration missions to the ISS
and has more cumulative time and space
665 days than any U.S astronaut and more
than any woman in the world she has
conducted 10 spacewalks with over 60
hours to her credit
cycling orbit tank isolation valves to
equalize low flow pressure
Dragon copy
and that was the voice of Peggy Whitson
who also performed hundreds of hours of
research hundreds of research
experiments on board the ISS
for ax2 is private Astronaut John
trofner a steam Advocate business
Pioneer and lifelong space Enthusiast
he's been a pilot since the age of 17
and participates in extreme sports from
hang gliding to base jumping to High
Performance Racing sounds like a busy
guy John trained as the ax1 backup pilot
and during this Mission plans to invest
a lot of his time in Steam education
activities aimed at empowering educators
and representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as Mission
specialist Ali al-karni is an Air Force
captain in the Royal Saudi Air Force Ali
graduated with a bachelor of Aerospace
science degree in 2013 from King Faisal
Air Academy in Riyadh Saudi Arabia
having flown as a fighter pilot for 12
years Ali was selected as an astronaut
in 2020.
also representing the Saudi space
commission and serving as a mission
specialist Rihanna barnawi has a
master's degree in biomedical Sciences
from alphaisal University in Riyadh
Saudi Arabia and a bachelor's degree in
biomedical Sciences from otago
University in Dunedin New Zealand she
has been a research lab technician since
2013 in the stem cell and tissue
re-engineering program at King Faisal
Specialist Hospital and Research Center
you've seen the vehicle you've met the
crew let's send you over now to NASA's
Johnson Space Center where Leah Cheshire
is following the launch preparations
from Mission Control in Houston Leah
thanks Duke you're right I'm here in the
International Space Station flight
control room at Johnson where teams
staff this room around the clock to
monitor the crew and the systems aboard
the orbiting laboratory today they're
ensuring that the station is ready to
receive dragon and the ax2 crew since
NASA opened up the space station for
commercial activity in 2019 the agency
has continued to work with Private
Industry to prepare for the future of
low earth orbit NASA's long-term goal is
to no longer be the provider of a low
earth orbit destination but to be a
customer one of many purchasing
commercially owned and operated services
to ensure the path of tomorrow we have
to work together today enabling private
astronaut missions on board the space
station helps us to refine and mature
the processes needed for the future with
NASA astronauts working side by side
with private and National astronauts in
a new age of Science and Discovery and
we take this next step together as we
continue counting down to the ax2 crew
launch to the International Space
Station and as you can see it's an
incredibly busy time in low earth orbit
and Beyond and with that let's connect
with NASA public affairs officer Megan
Cruz at Kennedy Space Center
you know Leo we love our launch days
here at Kennedy Space Center and we love
it when we can witness them with NASA
administrator Bill Nelson administrator
great to have you here it's always a
pleasure so as Leah said it's been a
busy exciting three years here at
Kennedy uh since 2020 we've launched
seven uh crude missions to the ISS but
we've also paved the way for private
missions like axiom1 last year and today
ax2 so I want to ask you how are NASA
and the general public benefiting from
these private missions well we go in a
public private partnership and we go
with a fixed price contract
and
uh because it's a public-private
partnership the the private partner is
putting skin in the game or in other
words investing so that at the end of
the day the cost to the federal
government is less
and that's the way we're going back to
the moon and then on to Mars and we do
it also differently is we're going on an
international mission
and so as we have announced the first
crew to go to back to the Moon in a half
century uh it has a Canadian astronaut
that's part of the crew and I think also
what's great is that we're opening a low
earth orbit to new partners as you are
saying so you know we uh uh hope to or
we will continue to use the space
station through 2030 and then after that
the agency will transition to as you
know commercially owned uh stations so
how is that transition going what's the
latest on that well the goal is we want
to bring space business off of the earth
up into low earth orbit and to do that
we NASA want to concentrate our efforts
going on further into the cosmos and so
we want to bring in our public-private
partnership to encourage them to do low
earth orbit and therefore when we're
through with the space station in 2030
and it will be pretty old by that time
it's time to move on to commercial space
stations we can still what we NASA need
to do in low earth orbit by utilizing
the commercial stations and we've given
seed money to four companies to build
commercial space stations in low earth
orbit and one of those is Axiom space
Axiom is going to start their Venture by
the way not only of getting accustomed
to taking private astronauts into space
as this mission is it also is helping us
with our International Partnerships
because we have two Saudis on this trip
but it also will have
its first component of its space station
and it's going to dock to the
International Space Station so a lot of
exciting things as we keep saying
ahead so I do want to talk to you about
you know you've been alluding to the
Artemis program the fact that working
with these commercial companies to
continue access to low earth orbit it
allows us to think farther so yeah talk
to us about some of the international
Partnerships that uh that are helping
the Artemis program
well we have some 15 partners that have
if not built or certainly participating
in the International Space Station and
this of course is a huge structure 120
yards long you think from one goal post
to the other goal posts in a football
stadium that's how big it is
uh and uh they are very much uh you're
seeing the results of that public
private partnership here another example
is look at the phenomenal success of
SpaceX as a means of getting to and from
the space station so when we shut down
the space shuttle a dozen years ago now
we rely on a private company to go to
the International Space Station in this
case it's SpaceX
uh in July it will be Boeing as well any
words to the ax2 crew today
well
uh first of all I wish I were with you
and uh secondly godspeed to all of you
awesome thank you so much administrator
and I hope you enjoyed today's lunch
thanks and so again we were talking a
little bit about the Artemis program did
you know that NASA and Axiom space are
also working together to design the
suits our astronauts will wear when they
land on the moon in the next few years
here's a sneak peek at what those suits
will look like
this is a prototype of what astronauts
will wear when they land on the moon for
Artemis 3. while this prototype is black
with blue and orange detailing the real
moon walking suits will be white to
reflect heat and keep astronauts safe
from extreme temperatures NASA selected
Axiom space to design develop and
certify the suits they will fit a broad
range of crew members men and women
accommodating at least 90 percent of the
U.S population
the moon suits worn by Apollo 11
astronauts in 1969 had a bulky life
support system the new Axiom extra
vehicular Mobility units or ax emu's
will have range of motion and
flexibility needed to explore the lunar
South Pole they will give astronauts the
capability to access live and work on
the moon future versions could even have
avionics astronauts will start training
with the spacesuits later this year
that's a look at your Artemis Moon
minute
[Music]
while the International Space Station
has been a valuable asset for space
research and exploration the rise of
commercial space flight is opening new
doors those benefiting from the new
opportunities range from small
commercial entities all the way to
National Space agencies
this expansion of participation in space
is enabling a more diverse and inclusive
space industry with a much wider range
of perspectives ideas and expertise
additionally the competitive nature of
commercial activities means the cost of
participating is falling and there are
more participants to share those costs
and the risks expanding access to space
Also promotes Innovation and scientific
and technological progress benefiting
Humanity as a whole
for a long time the conversation has
been about someday having private space
flights and someday we'll have private
astronauts well there's a lot a lot of
room to grow from that that someday is
now low earth orbit is more accessible
than ever before as space research and
Technology enter a new era companies
like Axiom space are expanding this
access and young space agencies like the
Saudi space Commission Now have a path
to achieve their goals in low earth
orbit at Kennedy Space Center is Axiom
space's director of digital strategy
Sonia gavonkar McKay and with her is a
member of the Saudi space commission to
talk about their goals for this Mission
Sonia
thanks so much Duke as you mentioned I'm
joined by Ahmed al-gafali of the Saudi
space commission but also Axiom space's
Chief Revenue officer tejpal Bhatia and
I'm going to jump right in here because
we're so close to launch time this is
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia's second
flight into space the first was in 1985
on the sts-51g what does this mission
mean for the nation and the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia
I believe that the kingdom has gone a
long way since 1985. so many satellites
have been launched ever since so many
payloads have been developed ever since
lots of research were conducted related
to space payloads conducts a lot of
components that we've done that could be
used for space and other sectors
so uh that's a long way since since that
time and here we are today just an hour
away from this historical mission that
will carry two Saudi astronauts for the
first time to the International Space
Station however I do believe that it's
not only Saudi that has gone a long way
I looked at so many research and so many
Financial forecasts that suggest that
within the past 20 years 60 of the
investment in space only happened within
the past two or three years so there is
a momentum and we want to be a part of
it that's wonderful
your efforts with KSA and the efforts
that Axiom space puts into this Mission
allow for a vision for so much in low
earth aerobic what can Axiom space
really do to help Nations like the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and so many
others achieve their goals thanks Sonia
when I think about what we're doing with
the Kingdom from the first time I met
Ahmed my definition of the word partner
has fundamentally changed and evolved uh
from when this was an idea and started
formulating as a mission to execution we
had to overcome a lot of challenges and
these are things that are being done for
the first time in human history and what
I've seen in our relationship is that
definition of partnership to overcome
those problems and make these things a
reality are enormous and what is
happening in this situation is while we
are enabling the kingdom to get to the
International Space Station the kingdom
is enabling us to see our vision of
providing access to all nations in the
world and increasing the Cadence of
astronauts from every nation to go up
into low earth orbit that's wonderful
this astronaut program is new for the
kingdom how has this process evolved
through this year are you seeing that
it's exponentially growing like the
infrastructure is of course of course I
mean when we started this program about
a year ago with this collaboration with
Axiom the first thing that we started is
for the process of the selection which
is one of the main and major Milestones
to achieve any successful program like
that so we built a program for a
selection based on the best practices
that we developed together based on the
benchmarks from from NASA for instance
however that's only a part of it then
comes to if you want to build a program
you want to make sure that all the
enablers are in place especially when it
comes to the infrastructure and also for
the right people with the right
competencies to be able to run such a
complex program so we've been building
for the past year utilizing this project
as as a vehicle to train to get those
people with the right competencies not
only to do the training for the
astronaut core but also you want to even
for the media for the finance for the
legal for the r d for the integration
all of it is a part of this secret
recipe to uh to get a successful program
and this is only the start so we're
gonna keep building and enhancing this
program till we get to the to the point
that is optimal excellent we have only
about one minute left what's it like
working with individuals versus Nations
what's the difference in that
relationship like for Axiom space yeah
so you know trying to compare uh private
astronaut with a national astronaut is
like asking me to compare my children
luckily I only have one child so I'm
prepared to do this uh let's start with
what's the same uh each of these
individuals on this mission right now
are pioneers very few people in human
history have been to the International
Space Station today we're going to see
three more join and each individual
represents their country and humanity
and they're going to inspire girls and
boys all over the world today and moving
forward the big difference is with the
kingdom seeing this more as a program
right you know when we were inspired as
kids I'll speak about myself coming here
with my parents or seeing the shuttle
program it was a long time before it
became a reality and what we're going to
see with the kingdom is is happening
more and more as we go forward and as
they say the sky's the limit for this
Partnerships the opportunities for
Nations individuals to grow together
thank you to both of you for joining me
and we're getting so close to launch so
I'll let you get back to it as we toss
it back to Hawthorne where I'm sure
you're feeling the anticipation it's
it's getting so exciting out there what
does it feel like to you and I know John
I is out there as well
thank you Sonya and yes it's a time
where the energy is increasing
especially we're inside of 47 minutes to
launch currently the SpaceX launch
director is checking with the dragon
mission director make sure that the
dragon ground team is ready to begin
propellant loading in just over 10
minutes from now
SpaceX launch director is also
electronically pulling the seven members
of the SpaceX launch Team for their go
to load propellant and launch
and once we get that go when we get
green lights across the board here on
the procedure
the launch director will then come back
and make a series of announcements
they'll talk about the control room what
to do during the countdown as well as
protocols for hold and launch Escape
coming up on 46 minutes they're
continuing to get the goes from the team
electronically
we're waiting to hear the launch
director give those instructions that
ought to come within the next minute
now once we get through the instructions
that will give the clearance to retract
the crew access arm
uh that will then set up for arming of
the launch Escape system
and that will take us into propellant
load itself that will begin at T minus
35 minutes you can see on the monitor
the crew on the right hand side they're
getting ready for their final directions
here
on the left side we've got the dragon
caps with the crew access on poles
complete and the team is ready for crew
Access Army Track propellant load and
launch reminder for control room
lockdown for all operators and Mission
Control and firing room 4.
both control rooms will go to lockdown
at T minus 45 minutes which is now and
remain in that state until the launch
Escape system is disarmed
all operators remain through console and
maintain a sterile cockpit until MD
confirms successful disarming launch
Escape system following orbital
insertion or propellant offloads in the
event of a scrub
reminder on hold and launch Escape
protocol for non-urgent no-go conditions
brief CE or LD they will approve a
boarding to countdown
urgent issues affecting the safety of
the operation operator shall call hold
hold hold hold on account down net
launch control will launch immediately
and proceed into the launchable auto
sequence
T minus 10 seconds launch control be
hands off and relying on automated abort
criteria for the remainder of the count
finally operators shall advise launch
director whether structural breakup or
fire is imminent or occurring for Dragon
manual Escape flight rules
finally regarding leak through on the
first stage ACS isolation valve we will
manually monitor
the pressure in the manifold
stage one will assess and a T minus 35
seconds indicate whether the pressure
rise is within the predicted range if it
is not stage one will call a hold on the
countdown net are there any questions
hearing no questions launch control you
may proceed with arming the crew arm for
movement
well we're going to proceed with arm
retraction two axis arm Kate it's going
to begin retracting we're getting into
the next Dynamic phase where a lot of
events start happening over the next 10
minutes
now while we wait for the arm to begin
moving currently Falcon 9 Dragon
continue to be go obviously we've
completed the poll the range continues
to be go for launch they're monitoring
clearance area around the pad and there
goes the arm beginning to move the view
from on top of the fixed service
structure
and the weather continues to be
acceptable for launch as we get ever
closer
nice view from the camera inside the
Lightroom
as the arm moves away from dragon
the clock continues to the clock
continues to tick down we're now at T
minus 42 minutes mark on the dot access
arm retraction is complete as you just
heard there that crew access arm is now
completely stowed it is now in the
launch position of course necessary in
order to clear the way for Falcon 9 to
lift off
now next up we will hear that we'll hear
the call out that they launch Escape
system is going to be armed and from
there we'll hear that Falcon 9
propellant load will also begin Dragon
SpaceX viewer go for Section six close
visors and arm launch Escape system
we saw our ax2 crew members exit the
brand new suit up room located in the
Falcon support building just about three
hours ago
they also got their tablets
visors are closed and we're arming the
launch Escape system now
those tablets provide them with all the
information they'll need for the mission
you see them attached to their left legs
shortly after that point the crew took
one last ride in the Teslas to launch
pad 39a ascended the fixed service
structure sign the white wall and
ingressed into Dragon after getting
buckled in the spacecraft hatch was
closed the closeout technicians cleared
the pad leaving just the crew members
inside the dragon vehicle
all right so as we heard the call out we
are arming the launch Escape system
which is a system that basically gives
the crew options a pathway to safety
through All Phases to orbit uh you know
we take everything is verified armed
we take every measure possible to ensure
that the crew has options safety is
Paramount so there we just got that
confirmation that that launch Escape
system is now armed so let's take a look
at the teams that are actually working
together to make sure this mission is a
success SpaceX is operating out of two
control Rooms Today there on your screen
a live view of our launch control in
firing room 4 at Cape Canaveral this
team is responsible for monitoring
Falcon 9 throughout the countdown and
launch second we have Mission Control
here at SpaceX headquarters in Hawthorne
California
this team in Mission Control is
responsible for close monitoring of the
crew and dragon every step of the way as
the spacecraft orbits the planet along
its customized flight path
on Console or headset there are a number
of key positions who are monitoring the
health of the vehicle and crew the
mission director that person is
responsible for Mission success and they
are in charge of the room today's
Mission director is Ken gamerek
other positions are focused on things
like software propulsion navigation
avionics life support systems and
Communications with ground segments as
we've heard those kind of called out
throughout the day so far you'll also
hear a specific person dedicated to
communicating with the ax2 crew they are
the crew operations responsible engineer
or core
c-o-r-e today's SpaceX core is Arthur
barriolt we've heard him a number of
times through the launch countdown
SpaceX team members will also rotate and
hand off coverage to ensure that we have
people on Console 24 7 for the crew and
uh and dragon for the entire duration of
the mission including all the way
through Splashdown
and for Axiom space the teams in Houston
are utilizing Axiom Mission Control
Center an officially certified
controlled center from the secure
facility teams have live access to voice
video and data from the ISS and can work
alongside their NASA counterparts to run
on-orbit operations and monitor every
aspect of the mission in real time this
room is led by what we call the axle or
the Axiom operations lead and around the
room are positions for officers
responsible for research Communications
medical integration and stowage and
timeline operations this is a
significant step in our journey to
expand access to low earth orbit as it
is only the 12th ground segment partner
for the ISS program and through this
facility we are enabling our customers
and the global Community a front row
seat to the work being done on station
we are now T minus 37 minutes and 31
seconds
from the second all-private astronaut
mission to the International Space
Station and the first for any
representatives from the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia Falcon 9 propellant loading
begin at T minus 35 minutes rp1 fuel
loading is underway on both S1 and S2
and lox loading is underway on Essence
we'll be venting for prep Talent loud
expect loud venting
with propelled low let's go check in
with John I
John esberger here from the webcast desk
in Hawthorne California SpaceX
headquarters inside 37 minutes counting
down we have completed the go no go Poll
for propellant load and for launch we've
just heard a call out they are now
venting down the tanks that's one of the
steps in propellant load the next major
activity will occur at T minus 35
minutes when propellant loading will
physically begin onto the vehicle
now we'll start with rp1 kerosene fuel
loading onto both the first and second
stages and we'll be loading liquid
oxygen onto the first stage of Falcon 9.
now in order to fly
just like Falcon 9 Dragon needs its feel
and oxidizer the Dragon capsule you can
see here on the screen it uses a
monomethylhydrazine called mmh that's
the fuel that's on board the dragon and
nitrogen tetroxide or nto is the
oxidizer together these propellants feed
the Draco engines that maneuver dragon
on orbit as well as the H super Draco
engines that would power the launch
Escape system in the case of an abort
scenario
now again coming up in about 40 seconds
we will begin feeling on the Falcon 9.
that means right now that those eight
super Draco engines inside crew Dragon
are ready if needed to launch the
capsule away from the Falcon 9 rocket in
an instant should there be any kind of
an emergency associated with the rocket
or the pad
but currently 35 minutes 18 seconds and
counting everything continues to look
good on Falcon 9 and dragon
thank you John
on the ax1 flight and during our launch
broadcast for that mission there was a
special emphasis on the Trish research
effort or the translational Research
Institute for space Health as the name
suggests has started
hey it sounds like a propellant load has
started
as for Trish as the name suggests this
is a broad effort aimed at ensuring we
understand and are preparing for human
health beyond our home planet this is an
effort that NASA astronauts and private
astronauts can both participate in
natural naturally life just a few
hundred miles above Earth poses some
unique challenges that we're still
unlocking the secrets to even after 60
plus years of humans in space here is a
bit more on the progress made during ax1
and what's ahead for our participation
in this critical research effort
thank you for joining us Dr Fogerty and
Dr yurcata from Trish the translational
Research Institute for space Health
let's start with an easy question what
exactly is Trish
yes Trish Trish is a Consortium between
Baylor College of Medicine MIT and
Caltech we are funded by NASA to
relentlessly and innovatively solve the
risks for human space exploration and
use a variety of tools to get there
including commercial space flight what
are the goals of the research being
conducted for ax2 through Trish that is
a great question uh the researcher we
conducting on ax2 has been highly
prioritized to solve the most important
risks for human space flight as we are
planning to go back to the moon and
going to other planets so all of these
projects have been uh custom made and
designed to be easy to collect to take
the least crew time and to take the
least Mass power and volume an example
is this kid that I have here we provide
one of these to each of the of the crew
members and it includes most of the
hardware they need to collect
physiologic data sensory motor that is
your balance how it changes in space
some surveys and also how the physiology
changes in space so all of these um are
have been again customized for
commercial space flight
framework for This research how is this
setup to enable new data for new Flyers
so they expand
patrish has two main elements to its
framework to accomplish the goals that
were just set out by Dr yaketa so we
have essential measures which have been
harmonized with NASA's standard measures
to make sure that we're collecting the
same type of data on every crew member
so we can compare across people across
different missions to really maximize
the value and then we have exploratory
studies as the second part of the
framework and this is where the known
unknowns the questions we have about
space flight are the risks have
hypotheses generated and we get to test
them how does the research apply to
those of us on Earth I mean some of us
are maybe never going to be leaving this
planet why do we care about this kind of
work Dr Fogerty Dr yucata
yeah this is where things get really
exciting so due to the constraints of
space flight and the complexity we have
to be really focused on creating
integrated and Holistic Solutions we
can't have individual solutions for
every problem those constraints create a
really ideal environment to bring things
back to Earth to put Healthcare in
people's hands we believe that these are
going to increase healthier Equity the
access to health care and the quality of
health care which then results in
improved Health outcomes
how does this Mission ax2 add to the
range of data
that's a great question in the last 61
plus years of human space flight roughly
only 650 people have flown into space
and if we look at the diversity of these
mostly our male white Bales and what
we're seeing with commercial space
flight is a more diverse population
we're seeing people from all ages
younger and older as compared to your
government astronauts we're also seeing
people from multiple demographics
backgrounds training education and also
people with medical conditions so as we
keep growing these database of civilians
flying into space we will have all of
the tools that we need to make most
humans being able to to fly into space
Stay further longer and enjoy the
experience
for joining us I look forward to
watching the launch with you and seeing
the astronauts return and looking at
their data thank you thank you
we are now just under 30 minutes from
the launch of ax2 mission it has taken
an enormous effort from an incredibly
dedicated and hardworking team to get to
this moment knowing that that not
everyone can be here to witness it and
even fewer get to share a message with
the crew we asked teams to record some
words for this moment as the countdown
to launch continues here are a few
messages from those across the Axiom
family
Peggy you are an inspiration to so many
people around the world to me it's been
so impactful to see a woman like
yourself make such great strides and
exploration and Achieve so many
different types of Firsts my family and
I will be watching you launch and
cheering you on all the way to the ISS
hi Peggy Kelly and Delta here we just
wanted to let you know that we're
cheering you on we're so excited to
watch you launch you're an inspiration
to women and girls around the world and
you've been a personal inspiration to me
in my own journey to space we're so
excited to watch you launch and we'll be
cheering you on here on Earth
[Music]
to Peggy our notorious space ninja John
AKA Loki to Ali who is also known as
Slayer and into Rihanna our very own ray
of sunshine wishing you an amazing
launch today as well as a smooth journey
to ISS at Astra ax2 crew thank you Peggy
John Ali and Rihanna for inspiring the
next generation of astronauts from our
crew experience team to our axt group we
are so proud of everything you've
accomplished and we're excited for your
successful journey home send us a
postcard just wanted to say that we're
super excited for all the groundbreaking
resources you guys are going to do we're
rooting for you and good luck the
marketing team has been proud to support
ax2 Mission
godspeed eggs too this is the portable
life support system team we are very
excited about the ax2 mission coming up
and wish you all the best we're very
excited for you guys y'all are such an
inspiration and we're rooting for you
all the way through
we wish you a safe and successful
Mission we want to congratulate the ax2
crew thank you so much for all the
inspiration and and we wish you the best
on your journey ax2 crew we are proud of
you and good luck hey X2 all of us in
avionics wish you safe travels and lots
of fun godspeed this is the
Environmental controls and life support
systems team at Axiom space we're super
excited about the axu mission and want
to wish the best of the crew ax2 crew we
are so proud of you here at Axiom space
this is the systems engineering team on
the station program godspeed and add
Astra on this groundbreaking Mission
from Human Resources to you
we're sending all of our support to you
guys from here in Axiom headquarters and
we just wanted to say congratulations on
the ax2 mission hey this is Ryan Lee
from the pressure garment team wishing
you on the ah2 flight all the best
godspeed guys go team
go team go team go team go
[Applause]
Peggy Jonah Ali rayana I look forward to
seeing you flying in space and working
aboard the International Space Station I
also wish you to enjoy your staying
aboard for this another making history
Mission we are all proud of you and we
wait for you on the ground and Godspeed
[Music]
a big thanks to all those who
contributed to those videos and everyone
behind the crew today a lot of really
excited teams out there and a special
thanks to Kelly Girardi and the space
gal Emily calandrelli both big steam
education Advocates who you just saw as
well
they dedicate their influence to
increasing literacy and interest in
science especially for young girls which
is awesome you know Emily and Kelly are
both moms to young girls so it's safe to
say that they have front row seats to
knowing what is cool and inspiring now
speaking of front row seats it's been
feeling like we have one of our very own
looking at pad 39a with these camera
views that we've been getting all
morning and afternoon now let's take a
moment to get acquainted with the
vehicles that you see there on your
screen
the Falcon 9 rocket with a dragon
spacecraft on top together stand at
about 215 feet which is almost 30 feet
taller than the Leaning Tower of Pisa in
Italy Falcon 9 is a reusable two-stage
rocket which means it's kind of like two
rockets in one the first stage and the
second stage the first stage is the
bottom two-thirds of the vehicle today's
booster is flying for the first time you
can think of it as the large bottom
white portion and the middle black
portion so that's what we mean when we
say the booster the first stages were
responsible for accelerating
accelerating Falcon and dragon through
the Earth's atmosphere and into space in
order to do that it has nine Merlin
engines at the bottom of the stage
prior to liftoff the Falcon 9 first
stages stage two cryo helium load has
started actually and currently underway
is being loaded up with nearly 1 million
pounds of fuel and liquid oxygen the
Merlin engines on the first stage are
optimized for sea level they achieve 190
000 pounds of thrust during ascent and
descent the first stage accelerates the
vehicle through the Earth's atmosphere
into space and then separates from the
rest of the rocket about two and a half
minutes into flight
from there the first stage will head
over to lz1 it will do what no other
rocket or excuse me what no other
orbital class rocket in the world can do
it'll go right there make its way back
to Earth
today marks the first time we are
landing Falcon 9 on land for a crew
mission previous crew missions landed on
a drone ship stationed in the Atlantic
Ocean so pretty exciting first for us
today Landing back on land has a lot of
benefits for example it eliminates the
need for our recovery team to be
stationed out at sea for days and it
improves our turnaround time to get
Falcon 9 ready to fly again
now above these the first stage is the
second stage the second stage has a
single Merlin vacuum or mvac engine and
that ignites after the first stage
separates the second stage is
essentially a smaller version of the
first stage whereas the first stage is
designed to power the vehicle out of the
Earth's atmosphere and through the
forces of gravity the second stage is
specifically designed to operate in the
vacuum of space the second stage Powers
the dragon spacecraft to its targeted
drop-off orbit the dragon spacecraft
itself is capable of carrying up to
seven passengers to and from Earth orbit
and Beyond but as we've been seeing with
those views inside the capsule today
we're carrying four people we have the
four members of the Axiom 2 crew it's
the first private spacecraft to take
humans to the space station and the only
spacecraft currently flying that is
capable of returning significant amounts
of cargo to Earth like the Falcon 9
rocket the dragon spacecraft is also
reusable this will be the second flight
for this particular Dragon spacecraft
the this is Dragon Freedom that the ax2
are flying in today it previously
supported NASA's crew 4 Mission in April
2022.
now we are awaiting our t0 coming up in
just over 23 minutes from now the ground
operations teams are doing a series of
system checks to make sure both dragon
and Falcon 9 are ready for launch let's
take a look at what the ascent portion
of the mission will look like
and once we hit t0 we're going to watch
Falcon 9 and dragon lift off from
historic pad 39a and make their ascent
now about 43 seconds into flight Falcon
9's engines will throttle down to help
pass through the period of Maximum
Dynamic pressure on the rocket what we
typically refer to as Max Q it's worth
noting once we hit Max Q we'll be going
supersonic faster than the speed of
sound
Dynamic pressure we can throttle up our
Merlin engines once again from there at
about two and a half minutes into flight
we have a series of three events that
happen in Rapid succession first is
Mikko or main engine cutoff this is
where all nine Merlin engines will shut
off in preparation for stage separation
whereas the name suggests that's where
the first stage detaches from the second
stage with the first stage making its
way back to Earth for landing as the
second stage continues on its Journey
with the third event
that event is ses1 the second stage
engine start number one that's where the
Merlin vacuum engine lights up and
propels the second stage along with our
ax ax2 crew and dragon into orbit
as stage 2 heads towards its targeted
drop-off orbit stage one will execute
three Burns in order to make its way
back to Earth the first is the Boost
back burn where three of the Merlin 1D
engines will reignite and then shut down
this helps to head the booster back to
Cape Canaveral the second burn or the
entry burn helps to slow the stage down
in preparation for entry back through
the Earth's atmosphere
at about 90 seconds after Dragon gets
into orbit Falcon 9 will then land back
on Earth The Landing burn will bring the
vehicle speed down uh rapidly in order
to land back on land near the launch
site today around eight minutes into
Mission I should say that actually
happens about a minute prior to that
second engine cutoff yep you're right
Kate so as the first stage is back on
Earth the second stage will cut off its
single Merlin engine that was ignited
right after stage separation once this
happened we wait for that all important
confirmation of a good orbital insertion
then Dragon will begin its preparations
and separate from the second stage about
three minutes after the section stage
gets into orbit we ought to get that
great view from the Ford camera showing
dragon with its four-person crew
drifting away from the second stage once
dragon is a short distance away it will
begin checking out those Draco
maneuvering thrusters to make sure that
Dragon continues to increase the
separation distance from the second
stage
the nose cone deploy sequence will
initiate just before t plus 12 minutes
and finish around t plus 15 minutes
which will expose dragon's docking
mechanism in advance
all right that call out there telling us
that uh rp1 loading is now complete
on uh stage one
uh now in advance or excuse me on I
think we heard actually stage two there
um now that talking mechanism exposure
will be in advance of a rival to the
International Space Station now with
that let's head over to Leah at Johnson
Space Center in Houston for another
update on how things are going there
with station preparation hey Leah
hey Kate the space station team here in
Houston is focused on the critical
systems on the station and everything
continues to function as expected ahead
of launch so the teams have verified the
command path the ground up through our
constellation of communication
satellites to the station everything is
nominal we love that word and the
station will be ready to receive Dragon
tomorrow should they launch tonight
Mission Control Houston is go for launch
once the crew arrives at station the
Expedition 69 crew will be there to
welcome the ax2 crew on board right now
living in the station we have seven
people that includes NASA astronauts
Frank Rubio Woody hoberg and Steve Bowen
United Arab Emirates astronaut Sultan
al-nayari and Rose Cosmos cosmonauts
Andre fedaya Sergey prokopiev and
Dimitri patellen
flight director Greg Whitney is on
Console now leading flight controllers
on the orbit 3 team in Houston for
launch and flight director Marcus Flores
will lead teams for docking tomorrow a
reminder that launch today will take
about 16 hours to get to the station
with a docking to the node 2 Zenith or
space-facing Port scheduled just before
9 30 a.m eastern time tomorrow once
dragon is fully docked to the statements
here in Houston will assist the Axiom
space and space station astronauts with
leaked checks as they work to open
hatches on both dragon and inside the
station's pressurized meeting adapter we
expect hatch open to take place about
two hours after docking that's it for us
here in Mission Control Houston and I
will send it back over to the team in
Hawthorne Duke
thanks Leah and all of that is set to
begin in just over 18 minutes from right
now and I gotta say the energy around
here is certainly Rising as Leah just
mentioned once the crew launches they
will spend the next 16 hours in Dragon
catching up to the International Space
Station that time on orbit and in Dragon
will feature a variety of tasks
including some planned photography but
about half of that time is scheduled for
Sleep which the crew will absolutely
need because once they reach the ISS
they have quite the schedule ahead of
them
they will spend eight days on station
conducting a variety of science
investigations and Technology
demonstrations including radiation
protection research studies on how to
create rain and how to enhance our
understanding of dangerous thunderstorms
as well as DNA research with
nanomaterials and reprogramming skin
cells to help create regenerative
medicines wow
when they are not Hands-On with research
they will be participating in numerous
Outreach events connecting with groups
around the world John for instance will
use the station's ham radio to share a
message with students
beyond all that Commander Peggy Whitson
has assured us that each of them will
carve out some time to Simply pause and
look down at the planet below as it
speeds by at a cool 17 500 miles per
hour
my face would just be up against the
window the whole time on station just in
the cupola the whole time yes exactly
now as we've said before we have an
instantaneous launch window that means
that we have one second we're targeting
uh 5 37 PM Eastern Time 2 37 PM Pacific
time so just 16 and a half minutes load
has begun
that call they're telling us that the
liquid oxygen on stage two is now
beginning or the liquid oxygen on is
beginning to be loaded onto stage two uh
that will wrap up around T minus two
minutes
now I was talking about the
instantaneous launch window because we
are essentially chasing the space
station we're trying to catch up to it
it means that in order for everything to
be precisely lined up in terms of how
much propellant we're taking on board
and obviously we don't want to take too
much because everything about space is
weight how much weight are you taking
um and so we want to optimize our path
to the International Space Station and
uh yeah so we basically have that
instantaneous moment to take off all
right and that moment is coming soon and
as we approach the final moments of our
countdown to launch Axiom space CEO Mike
suffradini wanted to take a moment to
reflect on this the second Axiom space
mission
this Mission today is very meaningful
for Axiom space it's a watershed moment
because it's our opportunity to really
start bringing the rest of the world to
the International Space Station we're
honored that the kingdoms of Saudi
Arabia is flying with us here today the
two crew members flying are fantastic
they've done a great job in training
of course John schoffner's been with us
for a while he's a backup on ax1 we're
excited for him to fly of course the
commanders Peggy Whitson and while she's
the first woman Commander for a
commercial Mission that's a big deal to
us I really don't think it's a huge deal
to Peggy she's flown so many times this
is uh you know like riding a bike but
we're very excited for this crew and
we're looking forward to their mission
so you know we don't do this by
ourselves Axiom is a wonderful company
with the Fantastic employees they've
done quite a bit of work to get to this
point the commander is one of our very
own as well but our thanks go out to the
entire team that support us the Axiom
done a fantastic job in preparing for
the mission and the medical and all the
work that's gone into getting the crews
ready to go fly SpaceX which is a
fantastic reliable Dragon spacecraft and
Falcon launch vehicle have prepped the
crew and the vehicle and it's out on the
launch pad ready to go and of course
NASA we can't do any of this without
NASA who who has worked with us along
the way allowed us to have this
opportunity and will work with us on
orbit and of course the investors the
reason why we get to do what we're doing
is accompany and build this space
station and do these missions because
the investors that are with us along the
way so it's the entire team that has
supported us and worked with us
throughout this last several months as
we prepared for this mission thankful to
them all
[Music]
alright guys you're going to have a
great time on orbit we're looking
forward to seeing you there on orbit
from all of us here at Axiom we wish you
good luck in Godspeed
[Music]
just under 13 and a half minutes and
everything continues to look good for
launch of falcons
now currently Falcon 9 began
for today's lunch
we have continued weather evaluations
and for your awareness we are monitoring
an anvil cloud that is moving towards
lc39a
it's currently five miles away and it
just needs to remain outside of three
miles for lunch to continue the weather
officer is going to continue monitoring
this cloud and will continue to provide
updates to the launch teams how copy
dragging copies mail issues on the
vehicle watching the cloud thinking very
dry spots
good read back and just a reminder that
the city Falcon 9 valves the Falcon team
is going to be performing that manual
evaluation of the manifold pressure
until T minus 35 seconds and if we do
not pass those checks the Falcon team
will call a hold
if the evaluation passes there will be
no call made and we will continue with
the countdown so again at T minus 35
seconds following the manual evaluation
if we do not pass those checks the
Falcon team will call a hold but if
there is no call we have passed the
checks and we will continue with
countdown
Jack and Kathy's manual evaluation will
call or hold if it's not passing the
check expect no call if uh if it looks
good
I like that comment thinking dry
thoughts
now we're talking about propellant
loading
rp1 fuel is completely loaded on the
second stage
field loading is continuing on the first
stage we're just about full it'll finish
up at the T minus six minute mark
densified liquid oxygen loading is
continuing on the first stage and the
second stage both stages well underway
first stage is nearing a completion but
it won't wrap up until T minus three
minutes the second stage just began a
few minutes ago that'll wrap up a T
minus two minutes
as we get closer to launch we will do
various checkouts one is the thrust
Vector controllers these are what move
the engine nozzles around on the first
and second stage engine and when we move
those nozzles we call it TVC Wiggles
those will be done inside 10 minutes
we'll also be doing checkouts of
throttle valves on the engine
now the range currently is go air and c
space are clear the weather you heard
the briefing from the core up to the
crew we're watching One anvil cloud it's
within five miles but it's Gotta just
stay more than three miles away and we
will be go to fly
and meanwhile the dragon team also had
reported they're working no issues
everything is complete through the
countdown the comp checkouts are
finished the access arm is retracted the
launch Escape system is armed the crew
is strapped in and ready to go
we're coming up on Final instructions of
the crew we'll hear that of T minus 10
minutes they'll configure their displays
for launch you'll get the last messages
and then we'll go into the terminal
countdown sequence let's listen into the
countdown net
Dragon SpaceX confirmed crew displays
are configured for launch
and SpaceX dragging we can confirm crew
displays are configured for launch
SpaceX copies
and on behalf of the entire SpaceX team
we are honored to have you aboard Dragon
capsule Freedom today on its next trip
to the International Space Station and
the second Axiom creation
we wish you a great Mission good luck
godspeed and enjoy the ride
Let Freedom fly
you're the crew calling back to the
ground to Let Freedom fly we see them
applauding everything continuing to look
good we're coming up on nine minutes to
Launch
next major event is going to be engine
chill at T minus seven minutes
as John just said at T minus seven
minutes
we will begin to flow a little bit of
the super chilled liquid oxygen
through the turbo pumps
which that is basically chilling the
hardware performing an engine chill
prior to the full flow we do that in
order to help minimize the chances of
the hardware experiencing any thermal
shock when that full flow of super
chilled liquid oxygen occurs
now we can see some venting from the
vehicle now totally normal it is that
liquid oxygen just vaporizing as it
comes into contact with the ambient air
maybe this is an opportunity you know we
always use the word abort this might be
a chance to let everybody know that
there are abort call outs in Flight that
we're going to hear those are just heads
up to the crew that says should a
contingency occur there's different
actions that'll happen at each various
stage of the flight when you're on first
stage or when you're on second stage
that's right we should actually hear
Commander Peggy Whitson calling those
abort modes out as they are ascending
and really getting to orbit she is
tracking everything on her both her
tablet as well on her leg as well as the
crew display above her head so she is
able to identify at which mode they are
entering and those modes identify
basically where and what sequence Dragon
would take at that point in time during
the flight
now we're about 10 seconds away from
that engine chill
for the first stage
engine chill has started
all right right on time
we've opened the valves that are letting
liquid oxygen and kerosene fuel down to
the Merlin 1D engines on the first stage
our next major activity coming up at T
minus six minutes approximately we'll
hear the announcement that field loading
is complete on the first stage
and one other comment while we were
hearing the briefing to the crew uh at
the T-minus 10 minute Mark we also heard
reference to a call out that may or may
not be made at T minus 35 seconds many
of the checkouts of the Falcon 9 are
done by computer in the last minute
there is one today that requires an edge
look at some data if for example that
system had an issue that would be called
out at T minus 35 seconds right now
everything continues to look good though
on falcon 9.
I would
we also heard in the briefing that they
are tracking an anvil cloud that at the
time of the briefing was about five
miles away from the pad they are
tracking it it just needs to stay
outside of three miles so everything
still continues to look okay on that
front
the next call out that we'll hear in
about 30 seconds is that dragon has
transitioned uh to the terminal count
configuration
that's basically an indication that the
dragon spacecraft has taken over the
space the spacecraft's countdown and is
Will at that point be on internal power
at this point in time rp1 is now
completely loaded both on the first and
second stages
locks load continues on both stages
it'll wrap up at T minus three minutes
for first stage and T minus two minutes
for second stage
are pressurizing for strong record
pressurization call out we are putting
uh pressurized gas helium onto the stage
in preparation for opening up the clamp
arm that's around the top of the second
stage that'll happen just at about the T
minus four minute Mark the clamp arm
will open and about 10 seconds after
that the strong back the structure
alongside the Falcon 9 will recline just
about two degrees away we've heard the
call out strong back is retracting that
starts the sequence now in the ground
computer to open the arms and recline
that strong back about two degrees away
at liftoff Hydraulics will then pull the
strong back to a position about 45
degrees away from the rocket as it flies
out of the launch mount
see the arms opening up now
around the second stage
we should now be able to see that strong
backward track just a couple degrees
away from the launch vehicle
upon liftoff it will move back even
further in order to clear the way for
falcon 9.
looks like we can start to see that
movement now
this structure is what is utilized to
horizontally integrate the vehicles
while still in the hangar as well as
transport them horizontally to the
launch pad and then raise them to their
vertical launch position
and we've got the strong back is now you
see a little bounce there as it stops
stage one lock float is complete
and right on time stage one locks load
is complete we're down to just loading a
liquid oxygen on the second stage
that'll wrap up just after T minus two
minutes the witch point will have the
million pounds propellant onboard Falcon
9 Ready To Fly
we can see the vehicle continuing to
vent some of that gaseous uh or the
liquid oxygen that has now vaporized
Franken is in terminal count and is on
internal power
we have a live view there of the SpaceX
team here at headquarters in mission
control on the left hand side as well as
the Axiom team from their own mission
control as well on the right
Dragon SpaceX for weather looks like uh
the system has cleared and we're looking
like we're go for launch for weather
all right we've heard a good news
information to the crew gagging copy
we're letting them know that appears the
weather is going to avoid the area
that is great news indeed
just waiting now for the call out liquid
oxygen load complete on the second stage
two locks load is complete
dragon is an auto idle
Brown gas Closeouts expect loud venting
at Benning we're now
bleeding off excess pressure in the
strong back that's what's giving that
large white plume as cold gas meets the
warm Florida air and condenses the
moisture
coming up on one minute where the flight
computers will take over the sequence
let's listen into the launch of Falcon 9
with dragon and the Axiom 2 crew
FTS is armed Falcon 9 is in startup and
is now controlling
back in his in countdown
Dragon SpaceX go for lunch
tagging copy go Vermont
T-minus 30 seconds
T minus 15.
2 minus 10. nine eight seven six five
four three two one engines full power
and lifts off Falcon 9 go action
copy one of them together we expand what
is possible in low earth orbit add Astra
and Godspeed ax2
[Applause]
plus 30 seconds into this historic
p plus 36 seconds 36 seconds into flight
a great view of Falcon 9 heading to
space
power Telemetry nominal we're into the
throttle bucket is the first stage is
Throttle Down power on the Merlin
engines in preparation for Max Q
speed of sound as we're getting great
views from the first stage camera
looking back at Kennedy Space Center
complex 39a
stage one throttle up Max Q
I'm out of the throttle bucket take one
Bravo
copy one problem we're in full power and
that call at one Brahma that's another
one of those abort modes as we get
higher and faster the logic for drug and
should a contingency occur changes from
stage to State kill is underway
chill announcement says we're getting
the turbo pump on the second stage
engine cooled down in preparation for
its light up coming up in just another
minute from now
again great views looking back and you
can see the contrail as we left 39a in
the uh the shadow of the contrail
against the cloud deck around Florida
now we're coming up three big sequences
and a view live of the crew inside
dragon
they're getting ready we're gonna get
three events here main engine cut off
Staples
and then we're gonna light the second
stage engine we've heard the throttle
down in preparation for stage separation
State separation confirmed copy two
output
and back ignition
stage one boost back startup
all right stage separation we've lit the
second stage engine the first stage is
into the Boost back burn working its way
back towards Cape Canaveral
views on the left side that's the first
stage engines running as we come back to
the launch site or the landing site
second stage engine nozzle is visible on
the right side as we're powering the
Axiom 2 crew into low earth orbit on the
way to the International Space Station
waiting for call out that the Boost back
burn is complete
stage one boost back shut down
right on time first stage completed the
first of three Burns heading back to the
landing site
second stage continuing on Power and on
trajectory
acquisition Casino Bermuda
we head Northeast the Bermuda ground
station SpaceX trajectory nominal
Bermuda is listening into the vehicle
nominal trajectory
and the crew here's the call out of a
so four minutes into flight everything
continuing to go well first days heading
back and there's the crew on the second
stage getting the ride into orbit to the
space station
coming up we're waiting for the next
trajectory call out from the guidance
officer Dragon SpaceX trajectory nominal
ah love to hear those words a nominal
trajectory for Dragons nominal
trajectory
and maybe even a little bit of
excitement in the crew's voice
Commander Peggy Whitson calling back
down hearing that call out from GNC of a
nominal trajectory
left side of the screen you can see the
first stage
it's now beginning to orient itself so
that the engines are pointed down
towards the land as we will be
descending towards Landing Zone one in
Cape Canaveral the four titanium grid
fins have all deployed they'll help
guide
they'll guide the first stage through
the once we get into the atmosphere
following the
entry burn which will be coming up here
in another couple of minutes
on the right hand side the second stage
with the Dragon capsule on top heading
up the Eastern Seaboard of the U.S we've
just heard the call out of Boston that's
the New Hampshire tracking station has
picked up the signal
Dragon SpaceX trajectory nominal
you can't see continuing to make those
callouts that we want to hear everything
and the crew echoing them right back
down
good comes with the crew we've been able
to bring some live video shots from
inside the capsule as they're headed to
space
and there's another view of the crew
stage one entry burn startup
and there we heard that the startup burn
for that stage one booster you can see
it there on the left hand side of your
screen has now begun
stage one entry burn shutdown
and conclusion of that entry burned that
burn helps to slow the vehicle down as
it re-enters the Earth's atmosphere the
first day the first stage sees High drag
which scrubs roughly 70 percent of the
Velocity by the time
trajectory nominal
love to hear that call out everything
criminal trajectory
beautiful view of planet Earth coming to
us from the second stage views on the
right hand side left hand side our first
view of the space coast once again
this booster is attempting a landing at
lz1 stage one treadsonic
that booster is now traveling near the
speed of sound
live view coming to you from one of our
tracking cameras
we can see the grid fins actuating to
help steer the booster down
stage one Atlantic bird stage 2 FTS has
saved
standing by to stage one Landing Lake
deploy
Ed
you can see that first stage has landed
back at lz1 this is the first time that
we have performed a land landing on a
crew mission
coming up coming up next will be second
engine cutoff or Seco and that's where
after after that engine cuts off second
stage will cost for a few minutes until
dragon is commanded to separate
stage two is in terminal guidance
we're expecting Seco to occur in about
20 seconds
Shannon
copy Shannon
Commander Peggy Woodson continuing to
call out the abort Moats
Pico
all right on time shutdown of that
second engine
also confirming that the launch Escape
system is now disarmed Dragon SpaceX
nominal orbit insertion all right and
there's that call out we can confirm
good orbital insertion happy nominal
insertion
Dragon SpaceX launch Escape system
disarmed
we can see the crew playing with their
harnesses
now that they are in 0g which I think we
just got a view of our zero g stuffy
clearly the crew is having fun
already right after liftoff I think we
heard a laugh coming from Commander
Peggy Whitson which being a NASA Legend
and one of the most decorated astronauts
of all time uh it's amazing to hear that
even a space veteran as she said okay
still has fun
at liftoff
the next event that we have coming up at
just around t plus 12 minutes is Dragon
separation
that's where the dragon spacecraft and
trunk so collectively referred to as the
dragon spacecraft will separate from the
second stage
after that separation we will begin to
deploy the nose cone
which exposes the forward bulkhead
thrusters as well as the forward hatch
that forward hatch is what the capsule
utilizes to autonomously dock to the
International Space Station
going from left to right
everyone's having fun clearly we have
Mission specialist Rihanna barnawi
to the right of her is pilot John
schoffner
then we have Commander Peggy Whitson and
on the far right Mission specialist Ali
al-karni
we can see that the excess strap on some
of the harnesses as well as the writing
utensil for their tablets
they continue to play around with as
they are experiencing zero g for the
first time at least we can say that for
three of the four astronauts on board
today
and we are standing by for Dragon
separation
which is expected to occur in the next
few seconds
live on your screen that Dragon funky
capsule yeah I'm happy
that's a really cool
a very great plate uh wishing safe
travels a few words from our chief
engineer as well
thanks for putting your trust in the
Falcon 9 team hope you enjoyed the ride
to space have a great trip on Dragon
welcome home to zero g Peggy
that was SpaceX chief engineer Bill
Gerson here this is it was a phenomenal
ride
make sure you share the joy of zero g
with your crew
we will do that
already you can see dragon's Draco
thrusters activating
Dragon SpaceX nominal dehumidifier
activation and service section Draco
checkouts nosco deploy is in progress
hooks are opening
Dragon copies
all right great news there to let us
know that the hooks there are two sets
two sets of hooks that are now
disengaging
and once that is complete we are able to
deploy uh open the nose cone
we should see that nose cone deploy
in about a minute
it's a great view on the right hand side
of your screen from the Falcon 9 second
stage looking at
the dragon Freedom capsule
of course the crew on the left hand side
playfully acclimating to their new zero
g environment
you can see the zero g indicator
in the background
and I love this view this view is over
the shoulders of Commander Peggy Whitson
who here is on the left hand side or the
left seat and pilot John schoffner is on
the right seat here looking at what
they're looking at this these are the
the crew display panels that they
utilize in flight to track which
thrusters are firing what phase of the
mission that they are in as you can see
where they are around the globe
all right as we can see crew getting
acclimated the uh nose cone hooks are in
the process of being disengaged so they
are starting to open
um and once those uh that is complete we
are able to open the nose cone and
expose the forward hatch
so incredible
well today's launch is certainly one
more for the history books and yet the
story is just getting underway Leah with
the crew officially on their way to the
International Space Station how are
things tracking their emission control
at Johnson Space Center
hey Duke well the chase has officially
begun with dragon uh heading toward the
International Space Station so with
successful launch of Axia mission 2 at
37 p.m Eastern the teams here at nasus
Johnson Space Center are going to be
monitoring dragon's flight to the
International Space Station over the
next 16 hours our role in this journey
really kicks in at a period called
integrated operations this is where
Dragon is much closer to the station and
at this point NASA SpaceX and Axiom
space teams are all in lockstep to get
the crew safely docked the teams here
are preparing for a docking of ax2 to
the station at about 9 30 a.m eastern
time tomorrow we're going to be begin
joint coverage of that phase at 7 30 a.m
eastern time but for now that'll be it
for us in Mission Control Houston
tonight and I'll be back with you
tomorrow for docking back to you Kate
and Duke
yeah now over the next 16 hours Dragon
will execute a series of burns to
gradually raise and line up the ax2 crew
for docking with the International Space
Station and what we refer to as
activation and Rendezvous phase of the
mission now in just a few minutes the
crew will get to get to change out of
their spacesuits and get a little bit
more comfortable for flight and will
enjoy their first meal aboard the
spacecraft I'm sure that'll be a lot of
fun the first time for three of them
eating in microgravity
at 2 p.m Pacific they will get ready for
a rest period that will last about 10
hours 8 hours for actual sleeping and a
couple hours for pre and post sleep
activities and then before they arrive
at the station we'll have two potential
opportunities to chat briefly with the
crew on orbit uh one later this morning
around 11 10 a.m Pacific and one early
tomorrow about 10 12 10 a.m Pacific
while we're hopeful that one of these
will work out neither opportunity is
guaranteed as they are dependent on both
crew schedule and ground station
coverage but if we're able to support
we'll make an announcement on our social
media channels no later than 15 minutes
before the event start time but in the
meantime be sure to keep tabs on the
mission at axiomspace.com and you can
also keep track of dragon's flight on
spacex.com launches and even if we
aren't able to talk live with the crew
we will continue to provide updates on
the mission across our social media
channels and starting at 7 30 a.m
Eastern 4 30 a.m Pacific on Monday May
22nd we will pick back up with our live
joint coverage of the ax2 crews approach
and docking to station with NASA please
keep an eye on Axiom and SpaceX social
channels for updates as there will be
plenty of incredible moments to share
with you over the next 10 days and so
from all of us at Axiom space thank you
SpaceX thank you NASA this is just the
beginning and thank you for tuning in we
hope to see you soon
foreign
[Music]